zdf heute live herzlich willkommen
gerade hat russland vermeldet die region
luhansk im osten der ukraine vollständig
eingenommen zu haben jetzt wird
befürchtet dass die region bonn jetzt
als nächstes fällt und damit der ganze
bass in die hände russlands fällt welche
chancen hat die ukraine die restlichen
gebiete zu halten und die bereits
besetzten gebiete zurückzuerobern darum
geht es heute und um vieles andere
hierbei zdf heute live wie immer gerne
stellt eure fragen kommentiert in den
kommentaren oder per mail an zdf heute -
live at zdf.de auf den aktuellen stand
bringt uns zunächst im romberg
lucie jones grüßt noch im ukrainisch
blau gelb doch seit dem wochenende weht
hier die russische fahne der krieg um
die stadt in der vor den angriffen
100.000 einwohner lebten ist fürs erste
vorbei
viele wochen wurde um die provinz lohans
gekämpft mit lässig chance hat die
ukraine ihr letztes bollwerk hier
verloren die armee muss ihre stellungen
rund um die stadt aufgeben die russische
seite sei viel zu überlegen erklärt das
truppenkommando dem britischen fernsehen
die russen haben mindestens fünfmal mehr
artillerie als wir vielleicht sogar bis
zu zehn mal mehr
nach dem rückzug der ukrainischen armee
rund um les sons verlagern sich die
kämpfe jetzt weiter nach westen in den
worten des anführers der pro-russischen
separatisten in donetsk die
volksrepublik lohans wurde befreit wir
können bereits sagen dass unsere einheit
sich in richtung bonn jetzt bewegt und
damit werden die russischen truppen und
die separatisten wohl besonders die
angriffe auf die städte grammatik und
slovan zu verschärfen seit sonntag
schlagen dort immer mehr raketen ein
heute wurde der markt in slogans
getroffen zwei tote und mehrere
verletzte soll es gegeben haben der
krieg in der ost ukraine geht weiter
zugeschaltet ist uns gustav gräßel er
ist senior policy fellow am european
council on foreign relations in berlin
schön dass sie dabei sind adresse
bleiben wir mal gerade bei der eben am
ende gesehen stadt sowie ansgar schreibt
heute der gouverneur der region auf
telegramm wieder einmal zählen die
russen absichtlich auf orte an denen
sich zivilisten aufhalten das ist
schlicht und ergreifend terrorismus wie
bewerten sie die lage dort im moment
die lage ist enorm angespannt dass es
sowohl thorsten ja seit 2014 militärisch
ausgebaut es gibt starke stellung
systeme die kann man gut verteidigen
aber natürlich sind es auch zwei größere
städte die jetzt acht jahren relativ
frieden leben und die jetzt unter
beschuss kommen man muss auch dazu sagen
dass die russische artillerie an die
russischen raketen nicht sehr präzise
sind das heißt man kann nicht
unterscheiden zwischen militärischen
zielen sondern man schießt einfach
hinein in die städte die man sozusagen
erobern will es bleibt ja von denen dann
auch nach der eroberung recht wenig
übrig und beide städte sind auch
wichtige eisenbahnknoten punkte für die
ukraine also hier werden ja auch
reserven ausgeladen hier kommt neuer
nachschub an in dem sinn muss damit
ausgegangen werden dass ich das bonbon
sowohl durch artillerie als auch durch
die russische luftwaffe noch in den
nächsten wochen stark verstärken wird
nun werfen wir mal ganz kurz hier einen
blick auf meinem notebook und sehen
einen tweet von boris johnson dem
britischen premierminister der heute
getwittert hat er hat mit präsident
selensky darüber gesprochen was bei g7
nato letzte woche beschrieben worüber
gesprochen wurde und er schreibt aber
auch ich glaube dass das ukrainische
militär die jetzt von putins kräften
besetzten gebiete wieder zurückerobern
kann wie positiv sehen sie das er hat in
seinem twitter auch unten das
entscheidende angeführt am morgen mit
welcome führen also mehr militärhilfe
wird bald kommen und das ist das was
das entscheiden ist die ukraine hat
genügend soldatinnen und soldaten die
kämpfen etwa 700.000 mann unter waffen
es gab mobil machen es gibt jede menge
freiwillige das problem ist ihr fehlt
die feuerkraft ja viel die die
mechanisierte beweglichkeit die panzer
die schützenpanzer die artillerie um in
einem offenem gelände den russen
entgegen stehen zu können im infanterie
geländer in stetten da können sie zu
verteidigen aber man braucht zum
verteidigen eben auch gepanzerte
mechanisierte einheiten und das ist das
entscheidende
der zeit wo es bei der ukraine hat man
hat zu wenig und die kriegsverluste bis
jetzt werde über vier monate im krieg
die waren ja auch offen klinischer seite
erheblich und man muss sich ausgleichen
und das schwächt die ukrainische
offensivkraft sollten sich diese
waffenlieferungen beschleunigen dann hat
der ukraine durchaus chance hier gebiete
wieder zurückgerufen wir werden uns im
verlauf der sendung noch mal genau
angucken welche waffen gebraucht werden
welche schon geliefert wurden wie die
einsätze damit laufen ich sehe auch
viele userinnen und user interessiert
ist hier auf youtube rack zum beispiel
einen user namens nutzer mit 3 er
interessiert sich dafür wie die
panzerhaubitze 2000 wirklich hilft das
werden wir im laufe der sendung noch
besprechen wollen da nochmal erst
jemanden mit dazuholen der nämlich in
der ukraine ist das ist unser reporter
dara hassanzadeh er ist in levi fda wie
ist die situation dort bei euch im
moment
ja im moment ist ein gewitter und die
blitze
strahlen hier überall es gab auch gerade
eben einen luft haben das gesamtbild ist
dann schon etwas puky wenn ich das mal
so sagen darf die menschen hier waren
natürlich nicht sonderlich erfreut über
die meldungen aus dem osten sie sind
natürlich besorgt dass die russische
armee erfolge erzielt sie würden gerne
das gegenteil hören aber noch größer ist
die erleichterung dass es der
ukrainischen armee gelungen ist ein
zweites mario pohl zu verhindern dass
niemand eingekesselt wurde das jetzt
zweimal
geordneter rückzug im osten stattfand
aus weidenstetten und dass die besten
kämpfer nicht in eine aussichtslose
situation geraten sind das ist den
menschen hier äußerst wichtig und sie
verstehen auch diese ukrainische taktik
dass man so lange wie möglich positionen
und stellungen hält und dann wenn diese
einkesselung droht sich dass man sich
zurückzieht das tragen sie sehr wohl mit
ein zweites mario pohl das würden sie
glaube ich nicht mehr mittragen
da hier im chat fragt ein user namens
daniel schuster oder sagt russland ist
ein lächerlich schwacher gegner jeder
weiß dass putin mit seinen drohungen
egal welcher art nur panik machen will
man sollte einfach russland einnehmen
wie sieht man das denn in der ukraine
also der ukraine sind trotz all diesen
wochen und monaten im krieg auch für
schwarzen humor zu haben
es gibt witze und aussagen die
bekannten humor einfach nur zu
beschreiben sind ich glaube man darf
schon zusammen für alle ukraine sagen
sie wollen russland nicht sie wollen
eigentlich in frieden leben und der satz
wenn man länger sich mit menschen und
erhält fällt dann meistens warum hassen
die uns eigentlich so warum wollen sie
hierher sie haben doch selber ein land
das das größte der welt ist es fehlt an
nichts an anbauflächen es reicht vom von
europa bis nach asien und sie würden ja
eigentlich alle am liebsten einfach nur
im frieden unabhängig leben
was können die menschen im westen der
ukraine tun und was tun sie aktuell um
denen im osten zu helfen
naja über speziell über lemberg läuft
natürlich die gesamte logistik
hilfsgüter waffen auch flüchtlinge beide
richtungen mittlerweile flüchtlinge die
aus dem ausland zurückkommen aus polen
nach ostdeutschland die in
aus orten kommen die sicherer sind als
im osten sprich kiew oder auch die
obersten ebene oder lemberg selbst und
natürlich sind sie im flüchtlingsheim
bau sehr sehr aktiv gerade die stadt
lemberg ich hatte im märz ein interview
geführt mit dem bürgermeister andré von
lemberg und er sagte mir damals schon
die ngo s müssen hierher kommen wir
müssen die flüchtlingsheime hier bauen
nur nicht in polen und es ist schon
erstaunlich heute war ich bei einem
dieser flüchtlingsheime sie gehen das
richtig an sie haben eine modultechnik
entwickeltes containerbauweise die auch
in deutschland in der architektur
relativ bekannt ist weil man halt
schnell wohnraum schaffen kann der
funktioniert der funktional ist und wir
waren dort und da ist einer wirklich
vieles gedacht worden von
kinderspielplätzen von
gemeinschaftsräumen sondern auch
hausordnungen erstellt es ist zum
beispiel auf dem ganzen gelände herrscht
alkoholverbot zum rauchen muss man nicht
nur vor die tür gehen sondern aus dem
gelände raus es sind gärten angelegt
worden
daher machen sie wirklich viel
daran eine frage von ulrike über youtube
seien wir mal ehrlich wenn es weiter so
geht wie jetzt verliert die ukraine viel
zu viel und rückeroberung es noch
schwieriger als zu verteidigen so weit
der kommentar von enrique wie sehen das
denn die menschen dort wo du bist in der
ukraine gibt es dort viele männer die
sich jetzt noch bereit erklären in den
osten zu gehen und zu kämpfen zum
beispiel wie läuft das mit der
rekrutierung innerhalb der armee
also es gibt immer noch sehr sehr viele
freiwillige es gibt sehr viele menschen
die dort alles verloren haben und vor
allem
und das ist die größte motivation sind
die überzeugt dass die russische armee
und rousseau putins russland nicht
aufhören wird dh wenn sie nicht kämpfen
würden dann würden die nicht würde
ehrlich sagen es reicht mir jetzt was
sich erobert hat sondern er würde weiter
angreifen und dann hätten sie irgendwann
russische soldaten hier auch in lemberg
und dass es somit die hauptmotivation
was sich so ein bisschen geändert hat
ist dass jetzt für männer die durften
jetzt sei erstmal zweiten tag des
krieges die ukraine nicht verlassen sie
brauchen jetzt schon genehmigungen um
ihre bezirke verlassen zu kommen können
so dass die kreiswehrersatzämter immer
wissen wo die männer sind für etwaige
einzug in die armee
war eine letzte frage noch an dich über
youtube fragt jochen pence gibt es in
der ukraine eine friedensbewegung die
bereit ist für den frieden gebiete an
russland abzutreten
das ist eine der meistdiskutierten
fragen hier und dafür brauchst auch gar
keine friedensbewegung sondern es geht
die diskussion findet an jedem
küchentisch statt es geht darum wann
kann man seine leute zurückholen seine
brüder seine väter die im krieg sind die
soldaten sind aber auch sie selbst sind
ja in gefahr durch luft anschläge die
sehr oft zivile häuser und wohnblocks
treffen
nur die es kommt dann immer zu dem punkt
ab wann kann man denn russland und putin
vertrauen das er dann aufhört und
das ist die frage die sich jeder
pazifist anstellen muss immer wenn alle
ukraine im moment pazifistisch wären
dann hätte russland die ukraine schon
erobert das wäre ist glaube ich auch ein
fakt lieber daran nach der letzten frage
kommt die allerletzte frage ich
verspreche das ist tatsächlich die
allerletzte denn du musst noch ein stück
fürs heute-journal fertig machen wenn
ich richtig informiert bin aber die
würde ich gerne noch lust werden zu viel
natur fragt über youtube wie ist das
leben in levi fi ist der alltag alles so
wie immer geht man seine arbeit nach die
geschäfte haben offenbar trifft sich
abends oder sind viele weg kannst du das
ein bisschen schildern
die stadt ist wunderschön auch jetzt im
sommer selbst im gewitter die cafés sind
da die menschen sind da es gibt
brunnenwasser spieler lagen wo die
kinder rumhüpfen wirkt alles ganz normal
und trotzdem kann jederzeit der krieg
sofort
dich wie soll ich sagen nicht die ich
treffen im sinne von bomben sondern im
sinne von menschen die damit voll
involviert sind ich bin heute an einem
blumenladen gewesen und die gründer
retten dieses blumenladens dient gerade
eröffnet ist dass mario pohl ihr mann
höher gehörte zu den kämpfern sie hat
seit dem dritten märz nichts von ihr
gehört und
dieses gespräch wurde mehrfach von
training unterbrochen und da ist der
krieg auch ohne bombe und luftalarm
direkt weil heute mittag gab es auch
keine luft wärme spürbar und es
belastend also es ist nur auf den ersten
blick ein normales so ein normaler
sommertag
dara hassanzadeh vielen dank nach lief
und wir sind gespannt auf dein stück
nachher im journal da geht es um stepan
bandera den sehr umstrittenen für einige
nationalhelden der ukraine und die
äußerungen des ukrainischen botschaft
dass melnik hier in deutschland ein ganz
anderes eigenes thema wir freuen uns auf
ein stück und danken dir dass du dir die
zeit ist denn er sich krieg okay wir
machen jetzt auch ganz schnell schluss
danke daran nach lavive und wir machen
hier weiter mit einem blick noch einmal
in den osten des landes geländegewinne
dort haben wir also für die russischen
streitkräfte gesehen präsidentenberater
aristo witsch hat sich zuversichtlich
gezeigt dass das zitat der letzte sieg
für russland auf ukrainischem
territorium sei und auch der präsident
selbst versucht die moral seiner truppen
aufrecht zu erhalten
innerhalb der letzten 24 stunden hat
sich die situation an der front nicht
wesentlich geändert der feind
terrorisiert die grenzregionen sony die
stadt und die region hf sowie den don
was weiter die ukrainischen streitkräfte
halten diesem druck stand und vernichten
täglich den nachschub der besatzer wir
müssen sie brechen das bedarf aber zeit
und übermenschliche anstrengungen es
gibt aber keine alternative es geht um
unsere unabhängigkeit unsere zukunft um
das schicksal des gesamten ukrainischen
volkes
wir müssen den nachschub der besatzer
brechen wir müssen dem druck standhalten
sagt der präsident gustav kressl der
militärexperte ist bei uns und ich
möchte direkt in dieses thema waffen
jetzt einsteigen weil es so viele
interessiert noch mal die frage direkt
vom nutzer nutzer mit drei e mich würde
interessieren inwiefern die
panzerhaubitze 2000 hilft wie groß ist
der vorteil besserer waffensysteme
wirklich ist hier die frage
für die panzerhaubitze 2000 ist ist
schon eines der besten waffensysteme
dass die ukraine jetzt hat ihn bekommen
hat also ich von einem trainer nur
positiv ist lobt dafür gehört angeblich
soll eine panzerhaubitze 2000 ungefähr
so effektiv sein wie die drei
amerikanische einem triple seven das ist
natürlich ein gezogenes geschützt nicht
so mobil wie eine panzeroffizier das
problem natürlich bei der panzer bisher
2000 ist dass es nur wenige davon gibt
also sie werden dort vor allen dingen
eingesetzt wo er starke russische
artillerie gibt was sie sehr
weitreichend ist weil man die russische
artillerie die weit hinter der front
steht damit noch bekämpfen kann aber es
ist halt immer nur ein punktueller
einsatz weil wie gesagt die anzahl
natürlich auf einer 1200 kilometer
langen front auch leicht unter geht aber
qualitativ ist es ein sehr gutes gerät
eine frage von caterpillar auch ich
glaube über youtube das sind zwei fragen
eine greife ich jetzt mal raus bekommt
die ukraine auch weiter setzt
es gibt gespräche mit der slowakei dass
sie zwölf mit 29 aus der slowakei
bekommen könnte dass diese gespräche
sind relativ weit die könnte sie
bekommen sonst gibt es keine zusagen und
man hat dass er zum beispiel
ausgeschlossen dass frankreich welche
liefern wird gibt es da eher
zurückhaltung das problem natürlich auch
dass die ukraine hat das muss dann mit
raketen mit marschflugkörpern
die ukrainischen luftwaffenbasen schon
angegriffen hat beziehungsweise ständig
angreift die ukraine muss ihre
kampfflugzeuge die immer noch im einsatz
sind ja verteilen auf verschiedene
kleine flughäfen landepisten zum teil
auf bundesstraßen und autobahnen stücke
die gerade sind gerade genug dass man
mit dem kampfflugzeug startet und landet
ist ein sehr dezentralisierter einsatz
aber es gibt noch die ukrainische
luftwaffe fliegt und sie fliegt auch
relativ viel denn selbst mit großen
weiträumigen luftabwehrsystemen wird als
300 kann man ja in der größe des landes
nur einen geringen teil abdecken und um
überall ein ein gewisses risiko für
respekt vor allen dingen für russische
bomber darzustellen nicht in den
ukrainischen luftraum vorzudringen
unterhält man noch diese direkt einsätze
zweiter teil der frage von caterpillar
herr dressel ist es möglich dass die
ukraine die gelieferten waffen
zurückhaltend für eine gegenoffensive
da ist ja gerade auch immer wieder im
süden des landes die rede bei der
ukrainischen regierung von einer
offensive die da geplant ist für wie
aussichtsreich und realistisch halten
sie das und natürlich auch die frage ist
es möglich dass die ukraine dafür waffen
bewusst zurückhält
davon weiß ich nichts dass sie die
waffen und bewusst zurückhält ist
auch diese diese offensive eigentlich
schon im gang seit mehreren wochen das
problem ist es fehlt wie gesagt der
ukraine an gepanzerten fahrzeugen es
fehlt der feuerkraft also dort wo die
lücken in der in den ukrainisch den
russischen stellungen entdeckter stoß zu
touren kommt weiter die ukrainischen
kräfte sind zum teil ganz gut geführt
also taktisch viel flexibler geführt als
die als die russischen streifte das
machen sie das problem ist dann wenn sie
auch auf starken befestigten russischen
widerstand stoßen dann ist das
feuerkraft manko ebenda dann kommen sie
ein problem das auch stock dieser
angriff jetzt auch
zurückbehalten tun sie im grunde nicht
es gibt natürlich was das das einführen
neuer waffensysteme angeht immer so eine
sozusagen eine phasenweise einsatz also
gerade wenn sie mehrere gerät bekommen
damit sie erst mal im ausland trainiert
dann an wenigen besatzungen wie dieses
gerät umzugehen ist und diese bilden
dann in der ukraine weiter ukrainische
besatzungen in größerer anzahl an diesem
gerät aus und dann kommt das erst in
größerer stückzahl zum einsatz
dieser phasenweise einsatz habe er mit
dem ausbildungs und dem dem aufbau
logistische infrastruktur zu tun als
jetzt mit einem zurückhaltend für eine
gegenoffensive vielleicht können wir für
die nächste frage noch mal die karte
einblenden die wir eben gesehen haben
die zeit nämlich nicht nur den osten
land des landes sondern auch den süden
über den sie auch gerade gesprochen
haben und dazu gibt es eine frage von
stereo tp 95 wie hoch wird die chance
eingeschätzt dass die russischen truppen
nach einnahme des dollars weiter nach
transnistrien marschieren und die
ukraine vom schwarzen meer abschneiden
hier sehen wir es noch mal versonnen im
osten nikolov und odessa dann im westen
ja ja das ist eine der die ermöglichen
angriffs richtungen das zurzeit in die
russischen kräfte zu schwach um hier
weiter angreifen zu können aber wenn sie
den daumen fast vollständig erobert
hätten dann würden dort natürlich kräfte
frei und
man kann sie dann entweder um karten neu
ins gefecht schmeißen um sozusagen das
noch mal zu probieren oder man kann sie
richtung süden werfen richtung und
deshalb fasst deshalb für für
wahrscheinlicher allerdings hier ist ja
auch ein cooler eingezeichnet das ist
der untere buch das ist ein sehr großer
fluss sehr breiter fluss der schwer zu
überwinden ist und wo es nur alle 100
kilometer eine eisenbahn oder
straßenbrücke darüber gibt das heißt
hier hätte er auch die ukraine noch mal
eine eine widerstandslinie die man gut
besetzen kann nur brücken sprengen kann
muss es noch wirklich schwer machen kann
über diesen fluss zu kommen und könnte
das auch länger verteidigen also dass
das muss auch hier gesagt sein das ist
nicht so einfach wie es oft auf der
karte ausschaut eine frage von frank
ebeling ebenso über youtube frage an den
experten wäre es aus sicht der
ukrainischen streitkräfte nicht schlau
die russische armee durch entsprechende
aufstellung in die breite front zu
zwingen
also die erste phase des krieges da
haben die ukraine ihre flexibilität
jetzt
unter sozusagen besser ausnutzen können
weil die russen tief schmalen tief
gestoßen sind man hat sehr schnell die
russen versucht schnell in die tiefe zu
gehen ortschaften die sie nicht
einnehmen konnten einfach umgehen um
einfach schnell rasch in die ukrainische
tiefe und fiel geländegewinne zu machen
das problem das sie dann hatten dass
erstens die
eigene lage wirklich zu erfassen wo sind
eigene truppen wo ist der gegner dass
sie dann nach schulprobleme bekommen
haben weil die die
in kräfte überdehnt war dass die
koordinationsprobleme vor allen dingen
mit der vierer abwehr mit der
elektronischen kampfführung bekommen
haben und das machen sie es nicht mehr
jetzt greifen sie ebenso zu sagen hier
auf breiter front an ihr langsam und mit
wenig tiefe dann können sie ihre
angriffe besser koordinieren dann können
sie die teilstreitkräfte besser
koordinieren dann können sie
unterschiedliche
elektrische störung eine weiterer
zeitmäßig besser koordinieren die luft
an schläge besser koordinieren
damit machen sie natürlich keine
spektakulären siege aber so langsam
schlingt sich die feuerwalze vorwärts
und das ist für die ukraine
problematischer als diese diese schmalen
tiefen stöße weil die ukraine wie schon
vorher gesagt habe besser geführt sind
also flexiblere strukturen haben auf
bessere offiziere die können wenn sie
offene flanken haben diese nutzen die
können sie wenn sie einen rückraum haben
dann dann stoßen sie da rein schauen
dass sie die russen ausrichtungen
angreifend aus denen dass die russen
nicht vermutet und erwartet haben das
problem ist wenn so eine breite
feuerwalze kommt die hat nirgendwo eine
offene flanke die kann ich im grunde
auch nicht überraschend weil die die
geht sozusagen stur nach nach schießt
plan voran zuschießt eine linie dann
schießt ihr die nächste linie da bleiben
wir taktisch wenig möglichkeiten übrig
die auszutricksen
ich zitiere den einen sehr engen berater
des ukrainischen präsidenten von heute
michael opodo jagd der hat in einem
interview gesagt wir minimieren unsere
verluste und ein vorübergehender rückzug
aus der region lässig und lohans
bedeutet nicht den verlust des donners
sondern bedeutet dass wir ihn auf
korrekte weise zurückerhalten werden wie
ist das denn einzuordnen
der zweite teil der aussage auf korrekte
weise zurückgehalten der ist natürlich
jetzt sehr vage und
dass das ist noch relativ ferne
zukunftsmusik dass man die eigenen
verluste minimiert dass man die eigenen
verluste versucht hintanzuhalten die man
sich aus deutschland zurückgezogen hat
das stimmt dass es gab miese jones
kettemann länger halten können das
problem war im süden der stadt im
südosten und pasta gab es einen
russischen einbruch und dort haben die
russen wichtige gelände an im süden und
südwesten der stadt erobert und von dort
haben sie die gesamten nachschub und
verkehrslinien die nach lösungen zur
eingehen einblick nehmen können das
heißt dem artilleriefeuer jeden
transporter anfordern können sie haben
genau gewusst und genau gesehen wo die
ukrainer sich bewegen und das hätte
ähnlich wie die walze wie 2015 ein
verhängnisvoller kessel werden können
und da haben die ukraine geschaut dass
sie vor allen dingen in der nacht
russischer nachtsichtgeräte sind nicht
besonders gut ihre truppen daraus
bewegen und das illusions er aufgeben
als da sich eine exponierte position zu
bewegen
dann nehmen wir mal eine frage nach den
waffen nach den waffenlieferungen
kevin kokot über youtube fragt mal
hypothetisch wie groß wäre der vorteil
mit dem leopard 2 wenn die russischen
streitkräfte jetzt schon alte panzer wie
den tee 62 einsetzen müssen
das hängt natürlich ein leopard 2 auch
sehr stark davon ab welche variante von
dem ding würde man verwenden also ich
nehme es nicht an dass die bundeswehr
ihre neuen leopard 2 a6 c7 abgibt
sondern dass es sich um gebrauchte
leopard 2 4
handelt die von anderen europäischen
streitkräften schon ausgemustert wurden
und jetzt beim hersteller wieder
gelandet sind dieser panzer hätte vor
allen dingen einen vorteil was die optik
angeht das nachtsichtgerät das wäre will
gerät ist ein sehr gutes die kanone ist
auch präziser als die russischen die
durchschlagsstelle mit der alten
munition der unterschiedliche gas drücke
maximale gastro erlaubt sind ist es
nicht vor enthof auf die panzerung ist
das lieber 24 liegt jetzt hinter
modernsten varianten des 72 zurück aber
er sieht besser der trifft schneller und
er hat ein einen besseren feuer
leitrechner das heißt er hat einen
feuerkraft vorteil und er ist
überlebensfähiger das heißt selbst wenn
er getroffen wird dann ist die chance
dass das ganze fahrzeug mit mann und
maus abbrennt wie bei panzern
sowjetischer bauart nicht so hoch
gegeben weil die munition anders
verstaut wird und das ist auch ein
problem dass beide seiten haben sowohl
die russin als auch die ukraine durch
diese hohe verwundbarkeit der
sowjetischen panzer die eben bei einem
direkt treffer der durchschlägt und zu
magazin kommt sofort in die luft fliegt
und alle drei besatzungsmitglieder
umbringt dass die erfahrenen panzer
besatzungen langsam abhanden kommen man
kann ja die 62 über den kann man spotten
was man will das größte problem ist der
wurde milizen aus der generellen er zum
teil in die hand gedrückt die man extra
darauf ausbilden hat müssen weil man
eigentlich keine panzer besatzungen mehr
hat die mit solchen dingen umgehen
können und der nicht artgerecht
eingesetzte panzer selbst wenn er gut
ist ist noch viel schlechteres gerät als
ein gut geführter mit erfahrenen
soldaten bemannter panzer in dem sie
wäre natürlich für die ukraine der
leopard aufgrund seiner
überlebensfähigkeit ein ein wichtiges
asset weil die eigenen panzer
besatzungen dann eben länger überleben
und ihr wissen auch weitergeben können
und ihr wissen auch länger an sammeln
können als auf der russischen seite
damit sind wir dann auch bei der frage
nach der ausbildung bisher wurden ja
viele westliche waffensystemen nicht
geliefert mit dem argument dass man dann
die ausbildung neben der ukrainischen
soldaten irgendwie bewerkstelligen muss
und dass das nicht zielführend sei
zumindest nicht im moment wir schauen
gerade hier noch mal auf meinem notebook
und gucken noch mal auf die liste der
bundesregierung die die ausstellung ja
jetzt veröffentlicht was sie liefern
will an die ukraine was vor allem
interessantes ist der aktuelle stand
nämlich dienstag der 28 juni siehst es
wird wöchentlich aktualisiert
keine ahnung ob das im laufe des
heutigen tages noch passiert aber im
moment haben wir den stand von letzter
woche wir sehen hier 22 lkw erste hilfe
kids wir sehen drei mehrfach
raketenwerfer mars und zum beispiel 30
panzer gepa das ist alles bekannt und
wir sehen aber herr dressel dass er
damit schon viele waffensysteme
westlicher bauart geliefert werden das
heißt es spreche ja eigentlich nichts
dagegen zum beispiel
sie haben den leopard gerade
angesprochen zusagen der krieg wird
lange dauern es wird sich lohnen diese
ausbildung zu machen und dann doch mehr
und mehr westliche waffensysteme zu
liefern ja natürlich also die ausbildung
dauert natürlich eine zeit auch die
logistische vorbereitung dauert
natürlich eine zeit aber der krieg
dauert länger also ich hab das
zentrum liberale moderne im märz schon
eine schrift verfasst was man der
ukraine alles geben könnte und wie lange
das in etwa dauern würde und wir liegen
jetzt im juli schon in dem zeitraum wo
schon viele dinge auch hätten eingeführt
werden können hätte man sich damals
dafür entschieden desto länger man das
raus zögert desto schneller muss man
dann trudeln das problem ist für viele
sowjetische
waffensysteme verfügen wir einfach nicht
über eine einem nachwuchs kette an
munition an ersatzteilen weil mir die
dinge nicht mehr herstellen und dann
muss ersatz geschaffen werden also ihres
und klassisches beispiel da da war
deutschland er der erste staat der
gesagt hat weitreichend als faires
system das liefern wir und das war auch
gut und richtig die ausbildung wird
natürlich dauern das kommt erst im
november sowie es so wie es aussieht
aber liegt der kritische punkt ist die
sowjetischen flieger systeme s-300 buch
am 1 die raketen für diese systeme
werden ausschließlich in russland
hergestellt und da kriegt man einfach
auf dem schwarzmarkt auch nicht genügend
munition um so einen krieg länger
durchhalten zu können um städte länger
schützen zu können um wichtige
infrastruktur gegen luftangriffe länger
schützen zu können dann müssen
irgendwann raketen her die im westen
gebaut werden das gibt es nur für
westliche systeme jetzt haben die
amerikaner auch ein system angekündigt
und sozusagen so langsam pendelt sich
das 1 das ausbildungs argument das hat
in erster linie gezogen am anfang des
krieges als man noch nicht gewusst hat
wird die ukrainische armee eigentlich
diesen krieg länger durchhalten können
wird die ukraine in drei wochen fallen
nicht macht es dann sinn geregelt zu
liefern die mehrere monate in der
ausbildung brauchen oder nicht jetzt
wissen wir dass die ukraine überlebt und
das bei der gegenseite bei der
derzeitigen angriffs geschwindigkeit der
russischen armee die die ukraine länger
überleben wird als alle möglichen
trainings und ausbildungs auf wende
bedeuten würden das heißt jetzt sollte
man sich eigentlich an einen tisch
setzen unter den nato alliierten auch
schauen wie kriegen wir denn die
kritische masse an fahrzeugen zustande
also wo ist es nicht so dass sozusagen
der eine liefert fünf panzer und dann
nächste liefert drei panzer b und dann
hat die ukraine mit mit 30 verschiedenen
systemen zu kämpfen sondern wo man
ausbildung vereinfachen wo man logistik
vereinfachen kann indem man sich auf
gewisse plattformen einig und die dann
den großen stückzahlen liefert um eben
in einer materialschlacht wie diesem
abnutzungskrieg dann auch wirklich einen
unterschied zu machen zwei letzte fragen
zum thema waffen möchte ich gerne noch
bündeln einmal fragt ein user namens
partie sind panzer sehr wichtig für die
ukraine oder müsste man mehr waffen
gegen den luftraum geben und die andere
frage waltraud tee fragt über facebook
wie viel schwerere waffen braucht denn
die ukraine um überhaupt eine chance zur
rückeroberung zu haben mir scheint dass
das was derzeit zugesagt wurde bei
weitem nicht ausreicht
ja also um das zweite sofort zu
beantworten ja das ist also die ukraine
hat zb vor dem krieg einen bestand von
über 900 kampfpanzern gehabt
fast 2.000 verschiedene rohr artillerie
systeme und etwa 400 raketen artillerie
systeme jetzt ist natürlich westliche
waffen leistungsfähiger man muss das
nicht eins zu eins ersetzen was hier im
krieg verloren geht aber in einer 1200
kilometer langen front kann man
natürlich den ausfall verschiedene
waffensysteme und die die kriegsverluste
die die manchen klassen bis zu 50% des
vorkriegs bestand jetzt schon ausmachen
nicht einfach nur ganz wenige systeme
ausmachen weil die front einfach so lang
ist und warum schiedene richtungen
bedienen kann bedienen muss aus
ukrainischer sicht und das
sagt da gibt es in etwa listen was die
ukraine bräuchte hat ist natürlich
bemessener kriegst dauert mindestens bis
nächsten sommer
die die hören sich auf den ersten blick
natürlich for rent an
ist aber ist aber natürlich in einem vor
einem krieg wo die zwei größten langsam
ihn in europa aufeinander stoßen jetzt
gar nicht so gar nicht so abwegig da
redet man von etwa 500 kampfpanzern und
und etwa 1000 bis 2000 an gepanzerten
fahrzeugen und über 1000 artillerie
systeme es gibt ihnen hat opels gesagt
auch die altbestände an solchen geräten
also 109 gibt es in den usa etwa 850 um
ein beispiel zu nehmen dass eine
panzerhaubitze die älter ist als die
panzerhaubitze 2000 aber
nichtsdestotrotz 850 stück das ist meine
nummer
113 gab es in der nato im kalten krieg
in rauen mengen und
stehen auch in deutschland noch einige
herum die exportiert werden könnten in
den usa gibt es auch größere bestände
torfrauen also wir haben das gerät das
klingt alles furchtbar aber das ist da
panzer dass die ukraine braucht die
ukraine braucht alle dieses thema weil
der kampf der verbundenen waffen bedingt
dass man sich gegenseitig unterstützt
die ukraine braucht die kampfpanzer für
die direkte feuerkraft die volle
unterstützung im direkten gefecht
genauso wie sie die artillerie braucht
um gegnerische artillerie auszuschalten
um feindliche infanterie niederzuhalten
aber auch dann zum beispiel flugabwehr
panzer um überhaupt gegen gegnerische
luftangriffe die möglichkeit zu haben
diese gepanzerten reserven ins gefecht
zu führen sonst werden dir schon vorher
ausgeschaltet durch luftschläge bevor
sie überhaupt ins gefecht drehen können
und das gilt sowohl für die offensive
als auch die defensive man braucht auch
panzer zum verteidigen dann schauen wir
auf das was die russen möglicherweise
als angriff verstehen könnten eine frage
von enrico ganz über youtube der fragt
wie hoch ist die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
russland eine offensiver auf die
besetzten gebiete als angriff auf
russland deklariert ist dann eine
russische generalmobilmachung denkbar
und als ergänzung dazu werfen wir ganz
kurz einen blick auf die stadt belgorod
denn am wochenende
hat das russische fernsehen bilder von
einem mutmaßlichen ukrainischen angriff
gezeigt auf die russische großstadt
belgorod bei dem vier menschen ums leben
gekommen sein sollen das wäre der
bislang folgenschwerste angriff auf
russisches gebiet der ball fliegt in
belgorod entschuldung nicht in der nähe
von etwa 430 kilometer hinter der grenze
zur ukraine hier sehen wir es noch mal
also das könnte herr dressel
bin gespannt wie sie das einschätzen
eine false flag aktion gewesen sein oder
ein tatsächlicher angriff und um auch
mal auf die frage des users
zurückzukommen eine möglichkeit um zu
sagen wir werden angegriffen wir machen
jetzt generalmobilmachung
also was den angriff bilden und angeht
würde ich den präsidenten wenn die
generalmobilmachung es sehr
unwahrscheinlich
einschätzen falls die ukraine die kräfte
hätte zum beispiel grimm zurückerobern
dann würde die situation etwas anders
ausschauen weil die kriegen ja schon
also erstens per mail andrews russisches
staatsgebiet und die ukraine will will
es zurückhaben und dann würde man mit
mit formellen mit gepanzerten verbänden
über stoßen eine artillerie schlag
über auf russisches territorium oder ein
raketenangriff das hat es ja schon in
der vergangenheit gegeben man muss auch
sagen das sind
logistische infrastruktur die den krieg
in der ukraine dient ist laut genfer
konventionen oder landkriegsordnung ein
legitimes angriffsziel
bei diesem spezifischen angriff muss ich
auch sagen ich weiß wirklich nicht was
dahinter steht es gibt nur bilder aus
danach dass es eine detonation gegeben
hat wie gesagt es gäbe in belgorod
genügend legitime ziele für einen
möglichen angriff etwa die eisenbahn
verladestationen die bahnhöfe die für
den russischen nachschub nach ratingen
es gibt öllager dort die durch die
russische armee genutzt werden
allerdings dieser angriff war im
stadtzentrum
es gibt aber keine bilder von zb
trümmerteilen von raketensystemen es
gibt keine bilder die den angriff
hergang wirklich so zeigen dass man
rückschlüsse schließen könnte was da
passiert ist es gab in diesem krieg
schon einige auf russischer seite
inszenierte ford flex ich kann jetzt
natürlich auch nicht sagen ob es einer
bar oder nicht ich kann weder das eine
noch das andere ausschließen details
kommen üblicherweise erst nach mehreren
wochen möglich zum vorschein dann müssen
die unabhängig überprüft werden müssen
fotos auf ihre echtheit überprüft werden
da müssen dann gelände gegebenheiten
überprüft werden wo genau welche
trümmerteile wirklich runtergekommen ist
aber auch dass eine einen rückschluss
auf eine angriffs richtung auf eine
verwendung eines waffensystems wirklich
zulässt also das dauert alles noch und
das kann man bei diesem angriff wirklich
noch nicht seriös sagen weder in die
eine noch in die andere richtung aber
wie gesagt ein einzelner angriff es gab
diese zwei schon mal von russischen
militär flughafen bei rostock es gab
dort wurde die raffinerie auch schon mal
der ukrainische drohnen getroffen also
dass das gibt es schon solche
vereinzelte angriffe auf punkt ziele
lösen aber noch nicht die mobil machen
aus eine letzte frage an sie zur frage
was ist das ziel russlands teil ziele
wurden erreicht mit der eroberung dieser
gebiete jetzt frank die entscheidung
nicht frank ein user namens batzer fragt
über youtube was passiert wenn putin den
krieg nach der einnahme des don was für
beendet erklärt
ich glaube ist nicht
das kommt sehr darauf an also wenn du
das für beendet erklärt unter welchen
umständen das ist und was dann sozusagen
seine formelle position ist also in
seiner gegenwärtigen rhetorik ist ja
immer noch das ziel die ukraine als
ganzes auszuschalten und die ukraine so
wie sie heute ist
von der karte zu finden das problem ist
das kann er militärisch zumindest im
schnellen anlauf nicht mehr erreichen
jetzt ist die frage was passiert wenn
sich zum beispiel die russische
offensive
und muss dann einfach zum beispiel die
leute ausgehen und man einen einseitigen
waffenstillstand haben wir so etwas wie
das
2015 war wo damals hat sich auch die
ukraine erschöpft dann hat man das
minsker abkommen geschlossen und das war
dann ein sehr brüchiger waffenstillstand
der im grunde gegen den krieg nur ein
bisschen beruhigt hat und dann nach
einigen jahren setzt russland von vorne
an das wäre auch dann die gefahr eines
solchen abschlusses dass es eben kein
frieden wäre sondern nur an einen
waffenstillstand und das ist nichts
dauerhaftes wer sondern etwas nur
temporäres das kann man aber im grunde
erst dann sagen wenn es soweit ist
zurzeit liegt ja kein weder ein angebot
noch eine gesprächsbereitschaft vor dh
die diskussionen wieder krieg beendet
werden kann wann er beendet werden kann
unter welchen bedingungen er beendet
werden kann die sind zurzeit einfach
noch spekulation da ist zurzeit nichts
greifbares da wo man sagen kann das wäre
eine chance und das wäre nicht schaden
wenn rico ganz bedankt sich auf youtube
für die antwort bei ihnen danke für die
antwort an herrn gräßel den dank gebe
ich gerne weiter und auch ich bedanke
mich bei ihnen für das mitmachen beim
scream vielen dank für die ausführlichen
antworten das war sehr interessant und
danke für die vielen vielen fragen und
kommentare an sie liebe userinnen und
user und damit sagen wir von zdf heute
live tschüss bis zum nächsten mal wie
immer sind sie auch zdf heute immer gut
informiert machen sie es gut schießen